the issue of addressing is can I just
say in some ways very peripheral because
you can still do the process of aids of
differentiation without anything I'm
going to show you but again it's about
trying to communicate clearly what's
going on so you're given this function
right X square plus 1 square is that one
yeah now very hopeful that they don't
give you any surrounding notation to
tell you what is this is this a
derivative this is an actual function is
it a second derivative I don't know I
don't tell me okay
so therefore it's kind of up to you to
call this something and I'm going to say
you need to call it something okay the
worst possible thing you could do is
well first let's just expand this can
you expand a plus okay please don't
write this down okay new color to
indicate what's going on I've seen it
hundreds of times which is why I'm gonna
say like you might look at this thing
are you serious you do this and the
answer is I have seen too many students
do this right now we'll get to this
point I'd say oh cool I've expanded now
I'm ready to 80 differentiate and then
on the next line they say Oh will I'll
put the power up and then I will
increase that power and it'll increase
that power and a little part of my soul
just died okay those hot but equal
they're never equal Lobby but um they're
not in this context I have done
something very significant from this
line to the next
okay so Ben these are two different
things I want to give them names right I
don't want to just have different
expressions flying around so therefore
you have some choice and I've what your
two month I want you to make a choice
okay if at this point you start back
here right call this something please
call this something call it I think you
basically got basically got three
choices from what I gather at least with
the understatement you have already okay
firstly you could say that's a
derivative
that's the derivative okay do your
expansion and once you've done that you
add to differentiate and that will give
you why because differentiate this to
get that that's option one option two is
you can say well I have other notation
for derivatives right I could call it f
dash right I could call it this F dash I
will actually just write videos
expansion again I could call that F dash
means when I'm doing my AG
differentiation step I should end up
with F right f of X if that's f done
right you have one more choice using
that sort of you were picture that I
showed you if I said this is not f dash
this is not a dream even but it's just a
function is its own right then your last
option is to say I'm going to call this
last name capital F that's what I'm good
call the function now you choose which
one you like in some ways I kind of like
going through this particular process
cuz you're gonna beat this notation in
the future and it gets you actually a
way for the fact that this doesn't have
to be a derivative of anything it can be
a function over time and we're gonna
deal with it so therefore that's where
you get this and please please please
remember your constant and say it's a
constant okay so can I just rehearse
that right you have two options quickly
gonna add plus C to everything you have
three options are call it dy/dx then you
get Y or call it f dash then you get in
or as I've just call it f and they call
this capital F so there you have three
choices but please make a choice don't
just have them fly around unlabeled
unnamed
who knows what you're talking about
would y'all please turn to question 14
okay Tom
read the question with you it's very
very finely curved through the points
one six and negative 1 aims with its
second derivative y double dash be equal
to 8 - okay I'm gonna pause before we
dive into this question just to make a
quick comment because I've been asked
this two or three times at least so I
might as well probably more of you're
thinking about it we have this notation
for the primitive right that's what
happens when you need to differentiate
words there is no widely agreed-upon
convention for what's what's the next
one what's that in other words the
double primitive okay and the reason for
that is because they're tation this is
what I would answer every give us table
notation comes in language phones in
direct relation to how much something is
used okay so if there's an idea that
gets used frequently like say Oh on
Android differentiation okay that's why
if what's of people use it they will
give it lots of different names right
which for us is confusing but it's just
reality
the won't interesting and useful and
morally applicable and idea is that
we'll people who are going to grab onto
it
and they're gonna write it in a
particular and it suits the kinds of
purpose they have right now there are
uses for first readers and their uses
for second term is as well they tell us
a great yep it tells that Cook County
but very interesting
but it second derivatives oh sorry
second prettiest right he's a different
shape and anti-differentiate again not
that common okay not nearly as common so
that's why this is there's nothing here
okay we don't have one which I'm going
to teach you or this is what you're
going to see you want not gonna see what
the all the time you will have a serious
okay so you can see I'm gonna climb up
one level there D fridge it to get to
why - and then I'll climb up another
level and I'll get more okay now
probably gonna go about this well
clearly I need to get to like the curve
Y right so I'm going to go to
differentiate the first time we should
take it up why - okay so this first time
eight is going to turn into X and this
time I'm not gonna do the division I
think you guys can do it quickly right
this is gonna to the turn to x squared
so you're gonna have to divide by two
right which means that this is going to
turn into minus 3x squared are you okay
with that okay now to do that in direct
relation to as I said before how
comfortable you are with doing it you
can do that in your head
clearly that's a time-saver but if you
are sign you get confused and you
accidentally as you go from this line to
this line
you absolutely differentiate okay it
would be the first time someone's done
it then then do the extra step do 6x
squared divided by 2 okay I leave out to
your discretion okay I'm not finished
right because I meant to differentiate
it it's it this constant now because I
know in advance to get from this to the
actual answer why I am going to have 280
differentiate twice twice so Clutton is
going to appear twice and there's no
reason they should be the same concern
okay so therefore I'll go if you call
this c1 you didn't call it anything you
like really it's just a printable okay
but at least this way number one I know
it's a concert
number two I give this to Bishop from
the other constant that's about to
appear okay so
okay now we've talked about the fact
that if you go from a function to its
primitive where you climb up the ladder
you can work out what's the cuts that is
if you know something about the point
that this passes through okay but we
know nothing about why - let me get it
the question the curve that's why the
function itself the original one right
that passes through these two two points
right but they haven't told me anything
about what the gradient y dash is equal
to anywhere so I'm stuck with that
constant does that make sense that's why
it's still hanging around I need to eat
two different [ __ ] one more time okay
hey Dex what's going to happen the
powers gonna go up keV x squared and
then I divide by two which leaves me
read 4x squared 3x squared you recognize
that one how is going to go up to three
cents without data x cubed okay but this
costs that flight log and I have to deal
with it right like when it was 8 it
turned into 8x so see why don't you turn
it to see what X right that's how many
X's I've got and of course if I
differentiate this to go back here yeah
it would see one but look I'm a
different kid again so now I have it a
constant
now please the hard distinguishing this
from the beginning remember al Jane has
that crazy question what are you were
differentiating a to differentiate two
things and those two constants just
lumping together like that's true
because I early auntie differentiated
what but here I have to just extend you
see that right you do it once then you
do it a second time so that's why you
get the first constants and a second
okay now I'm ready to use these
conditions up here right I can use these
values I can pop them into here because
that's what they relates you they relate
to the original curve okay so I will say
since Y passes through again this is one
of those are one of those connecting
sentences to indicate where is the next
stuff where is it coming from where
these numbers are Ukrainians might be
from it passes through one six okay I'm
going to get two equations out of this
from the first one one six I've got to
get 6 equals 4 take away 1 plus C 1 plus
C 2
you see I've put in 1 cover 6 in there
did I do it right you can tip with that
I substituted x equals 1 y equals 6
I've been tightening this up just a
little bit back to 3 so when I bring it
on a bar and getting C 1 plus C 2 equals
3
you came with that now you can clearly
see it right I've got two unknowns gonna
be two equations and the other one comes
from here right so this point gave me
this equation and the other point is
going to give me a new equation which I
can then solve simultaneously right what
is the minus one so here's my function
so let's see here 8 is y equals 4 times
negative 1 squared which is 4 minus
negative 1 cubed what's negative 1 cubed
sir - - what - thing one is plus one
that's my result this is gonna be - I
see 1 and then plus their seats 8 so
again tidying up right I've got 5 here
when I subtract that's gonna be 3 is all
I've got
- C 1 plus C 2 e 3 and now I've got two
equations I can work with equation 1
equation 2 what jumps out you for the
way you would combine them this is
clearly an elimination right because
these two guys are just gonna cancel
with each other so it looks to me like
I'm getting if I add 1 & 2 I'm getting 2
C 2 equals 6 so 16 was 3 which means C 1
equals 0 ok now stop that's not my
answer I'm going to use that to say well
but this is what I said the function was
right and I didn't know what see what it
seats you were well now I know
so therefore y 4x squared take away X
cubed plus how many X's plus 3 on the
end